Let's say, let's say, so much to learn.
Today, I'm going to tell you the story in the world should I tell you about.
Tastes as lousy.
Sure is.
You don't know about all the discoveries the way Maestro does,
all the great scientists and inventors.
What was that?
Changed our lives for thousands of years.
You mean it?
Of years we've had cars?
No, no, of course not.
I mean the wheel.
We can't invent the car if we haven't invented the wheel first, right?
Then that goes back 5,000 years to Samaria in the Middle East.
This is off a beam, and then they attack to a board.
And one donkey power, it goes fast.
Interesting. We shall try it. If it works, you will be rewarded. If not, you need slices of a beam.
Oh, yes, sir.
We're used with horses, and even zebras, but even back then, people dreamed of having a cart with a motor, even Leonardo da Vinci.
Rings could make the wheels turn, maybe.
What if I, um...
Yes, but Leonardo would abandon this project as he had done with so many others.
The first true automotive vehicle would be Cugno's steam chariot. It didn't turn out too well.
A few years later, a Scotsman, William Murdoch, built a steam car.
All's after me.
The Frenchman André Lenoir will invent an internal combustion engine.
In fact, it wasn't to prove very useful.
Then a German, Nicholas Otto.
Ja, Helen, here's engines that will revolutionize the world.
You think so, Herr Otto?
I am certain it is the first explosion engine.
Explosion?
Yes, my Herr, explosion.
You want to see?
Oh, you see an electric spark is causing explosions of the fuel air mixture internally.
This would be the first internal combustion engine, so-called because regular explosions of the air and fuel mixture supplied the power to push the pistons.
The first motorized tricycle was made by the German Carl Benz, and the first true automobile was made by another German, Gottlieb Daimler.
This was to be the start of an extraordinary era. Everywhere they began constructing motorcars, each one was more spectacular than the last!
As you just imagine, in France, the Peugeot Quadridge, Pont-Ain, Le Vasseur, and De La Haye.
In Germany, the Benz Milord.
Back in France, the Renault.
And the de Dion Bouton.
In Italy, the Fiat, three and a half horsepower.
In England, the Wolseley and the Rolls-Royce Silver Ghost.
I'd like to buy 'em all up.
These magnificent old cars, they remind me.
It was an epic you know nothing about.
You weren't even born.
Neither was I, anyway, I don't think I was.
Naturally, they cost a great deal, and intended only for the privileged.
All that was going to change on account of one man,
A farmer's son in the United States and his name was Henry Ford.
There won't be any horse-drawn carriages in the cities.
The future is in vehicles with engines.
Nothing will ever replace the horse, Henry.
Steam engine isn't practical.
Look at that.
City, good horse.
There could be other ways besides steam to power a vehicle.
Henry?
Yes, Dad?
Troy, you want to come?
Sure, you bet.
She'll find it very interesting.
Yes, sir.
Whistle out the steam engine.
And it doesn't work?
No, it doesn't work.
Otherwise, you think I'd blow my lungs out?
You suppose I might look?
Yeah, one more know-it-all.
Here, lad, talent for mechanical things.
Well, I try.
Let me show you over here. Come, it's interesting.
A steam engine. A customer brought it in.
I can't figure out why it won't run. You take a look at it.
Sure, I'd be glad to.
To build a motor car with an internal combustion engine.
Yeah, I've heard about such things. It appears they might work.
No doubt about it. I made a drawing. Here, look.
William, I need Henry to work on your farm.
You bet I do.
I just got a large tract of land so that Henry would have his farm right next to mine.
i'll tell you no doubt about it he's a born mechanic if he wants i'd be glad to hire him
yes it's what i've always wanted i don't see any future in motorcars but if that's what you really
want oh it is dad believe me say uh mr flower yes henry what is it to make my car it could be
useful to learn about electricity i've been offered a position at the edison electricity
generator if you wouldn't mind absolutely henry you go ahead and if you ever want to come back
Here, you know you've always got a job.
A serious power failure over at Begley's.
Go and fix it.
Failure at Mr. Hicks.
Today, they're all waiting.
You're absent-minded, Henry.
Guess I'm always thinking of my work.
Go on, my lad.
Your own wedding's something not to miss.
I'll go and see about the power failure.
Get your help.
Tell you, when I tell you to, you let the gas in real slow.
Start the drops now.
Stop.
Now I know that I can build a two-cylinder engine as well as a car.
Henry, you're a genius.
Don't talk about it.
Not a word.
Be sure that I'm right.
Hey, dear.
It's right away.
I missed it.
I'll give her a test.
Too small.
This won't do.
I have to get her out.
Horses.
One thing they don't dirty the streets.
Oh, automobile.
No, huh?
Mr. Ford, these gentlemen and I are planning to set up an automobile factory.
Would you like to join us?
Yes, I would.
These aren't powerful enough.
Ford, your automobile is still not ready?
No, it's not.
I have to run additional tests to be certain that the automobile is quite safe.
You have already wasted three years, and we have spent a great deal of money.
You are fired, Mr. Ford.
I believe you're going to regret this.
Clara, we have almost no money.
Then we'll leave here and live with Dad.
I'll succeed, Clara, I promise.
I'm nearly finished with my racing car.
I know you'll succeed, Henry.
Come and see you in a race between the steam-driven cars and gas stations.
It's a great race.
There they go, they're up there.
One is going to start.
Mr. Ford, be a shareholder.
In order that, a hundred years ago, America already had superb Cadillacs, Oldsmobiles,
and in Europe, they were also starting to make fine cars.
Mercedes, De Diambouton, wanted to manufacture cars that ordinary people might own,
but the profit seekers were on the lookout for their profits.
Taken out of the internal combustion engine, and from now on,
anybody who tries to build a car anywhere in the United States pays me a fat fee.
It should amount to quite a lot for us.
Mr. Ford, it's a catastrophe!
A certain Mr. Seldon has patented the internal combustion engine.
I have to pay a lot now. It's going to ruin us.
Ridiculous.
It was a Frenchman, René Lenoir,
who invented the original internal combustion engine more than 40 years ago.
And then his engine was improved 20 years later by a German named Otto.
The Seldon has no right.
There was a real competition, and it was fierce.
There were over 150 car builders.
A huge automobile show was held in New York City.
Where can I find the exhibition stand for Ford?
You're not a member of our association.
No stand for you.
You have no right to refuse us.
I have a card order here.
Yeah, all right, come with me.
I'll show you just where you can put it.
Right here.
One or two more and she's all tuned up.
They put us in the cellar, nobody will come.
Oh, yes, they will, Kulik,
because a Ford car is going to break the world speed record.
I'll drive.
You're going to hold on to the chassis.
You'll have to inject gasoline rapidly under high pressure to increase the power.
Manufactured assembly line.
The Model T became one of the most popular cars ever built.
The biggest seller in history.
They were sold in their millions over a 20-year period.
Here, Frank, we're going to enter another race.
It'll be the longest ever run in the United States, Atlantic to Pacific.
We'll race two cars.
You will drive one of them, but I won't be there because I have to go and testify in court.
Okay, Henry.
Mr. Ford, you may proceed.
Your Honor, the internal combustion engine was invented by a Frenchman half a century ago.
Essentially, steam was not used to drive the pistons.
It was hot, expanding gases.
Mr. Selman didn't invent anything.
Twin Falls?
I'll sell 250,000 cars in one year.
Two years, we've cut the price in half from $1,000 to $500.
And I propose right now to double the salaries of all our workers.
Out of the question.
This is a business.
We're not a charitable institution.
It's the stockholders, not the workers, who are entitled to it, Henry.
We already have a lot more money than any of us needs, Mr. Dodge.
In a real sense, it was a revolution.
The workers.
And not only the bosses were to benefit from industrialization.
Ford sold like hotcakes, and they were used for all sorts of things.
Hey-oh-oh!
That's right, Frank. We've sold 10 million of our Model T's.
Guess I won my bet, because almost anybody can buy a Ford.
I think it was the golden era of the automobile.
The roaring 20s. Just look at these beauties.
Mercedes-Benz, Duesenberg, Hotchkiss, Rolls-Royce, Lancia, Hispano.
We're all pretty slow.
Pretty slow? Well, you just listen.
In 1927, the Golden Arrow attained 370 kilometers an hour.
In 1970, the blue flame reached a thousand per hour,
at over a thousand kilometers an hour.
And now you don't see a car go that fast every day.
And if the motor cars become a part of our daily lives,
we have Henry Ford to thank.
True, he also gave us traffic jams.
But I guess, in its way, that too is progress.
Démons et vagabonds tout ailleurs
Si que l'homme décolle, il va quitter le sol,
mais par c'est qu'il s'en va
Maman